>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Next we have Tahir Hemphill,
an award-winning multimedia
artist working in the areas
of interdisciplinary collaboration,
thought, and research.
He's planned business strategy
in the entertainment, advertising
and non-profit industries.
He also produces art and
media arts education programs
and manages the Rap Research Lab.
He's going to share a story about
how visualizing rap lyrics helps
to teach data literacy
to high school students.
Tahir, you're up.
>> Tahir Hemphill: My
name is Tahir Hemphill.
I am a artist, educator,
radical archivist,
and a creative technologist.
And I'm going to talk about my
projects at the Rap Research Lab.
My practice investigates
the role that systems play
in a generational form,
and also the role
that collaborative
knowledge production plays
in the resilience of communities.
So the slides that I'm going to go
through today will fit
in those two areas.
So the system that I developed --
the one system that I
developed is the Rap Almanac.
And it's an online
searchable database,
and it contains the natural language
processing of tons of hip-hop songs.
Right now, there are about 25,
30 artists, about a quarter
of a million songs, and this is some
of the data analytics
associated with the songs.
So in a database, we have artist
name, song title, the album title,
geo location -- everything
is geo-tagged --
and has release dates
for all of the songs.
And some of the syntax analysis
is the word count, reading level,
rhyme density, and this rhyme
analysis that will tell you
if what you're reading
is a perfect rhyme.
And also it tells you where the
rhymes fit within the lines.
And the sentiment analysis
covers sentiment,
keywords, people, and places.
And this is what a search
in the database looks like.
In this case, the user
typed in "power."
And then you get back this wall of
data -- song title, album title.
And then you can add these
advanced search options.
In this case, they're
adding sentiment and people,
syllables per word,
and redoing the search.
And he most exciting
part about this, well,
besides the YouTube view is the
fact that you can press a button
and get a machine-readable output
and a human readable output.
So you can export to
CSV and export to JSON.
And it took a long time
to get to that point.
It seems really small but I was
ecstatic when we got to that point.
So, what the database gives us is
a new context for hip-hop, right.
So there's content,
there's a location tagged
to the content, and there's a time.
So for every utterance in hip-hop
there's a time and a place on earth.
You can do, in that example,
the search for "power,"
and find every rapper
that rapped about power,
where in the world they rapped
about power, when they rapped
about power, and the context.
So it's a big data rap project.
So I'm going to go through a few
slides of examples of visualization.
So one of the first things I
did immediately was to just
to dump all of this in Google Earth.
And what you're looking at is,
or what you just saw was
Staten Island rappers.
And now you're looking at Brooklyn
rappers, and then Queens rappers.
So the project maps the geography
of the language of hip-hop.
So you can find out how slang
travels, where slang originates,
how it travels, how each region
influences other regions.
And that can be done for slang,
that can be done for politics,
that can be done for
many other things.
Another data vis, early
data vis that I worked on,
looked at champagne-brand mentions
in hip-hop from 1980 to 2010.
And of course, it's like
it's quaint, it's funny.
Like, you know, there's -- we
all have an image of rappers
and champagne use, right?
But if you also look at -- that
image that we get from music videos.
But if you also look at champagne
as a aspirational product and times
for champagne use that are tied
to expressions of celebration
or expressions of wealth or the
fact that you want to pretend
like you have wealth,
then you can dig deeper
into the cultural meanings
of champagne and rap.
This is a network graph that I
made that looks at contemporary
and modern painters that
are mentioned in rap.
And Jean-Michel Basquiat
became really popular recently
and it's called Picasso Baby.
And again it shows these
connections, this different context
between rap lyrics and culture.
And a recent -- well, a project
that I made last year
is called Spotify City,
and it deals with virtuality.
So I had a residency at Spotify, and
what I did was look at the content
of the streams as a representation
of a listener's aspirations
and desires as revealed through
the music that they listen to.
So the idea is that if
you're driving to work,
on your way to work, you're
probably not listening
to song about being at work.
You're listening to a song about
being somewhere else at work,
and how do we extract that
virtuality from streams?
This is a light pen drawing made
from a 20-foot-tall
industrial robot.
So using the semantic analysis,
I extracted the locations
that are mentioned in 12
rappers' bodies of work,
from their first song to their
last song, and through --
I think it was like a 14-step
process, sent these codes
to a robot arm and put a light
pen in a robot arm's hand
and had the robot arm trace
the locations around the globe.
In this case, it's Kanye West.
This is a digital model of the
same thing that we are developing
into a VR educational piece.
So the green paths are the
paths that the rappers --
the green paths are the
paths that the rap travels.
And I wasn't satisfied with
just two-dimensional --
or I wasn't satisfied with
two-dimensional representations,
so I'm also producing data
sculpture of this work.
And this is the suite
of all 12 rappers.
And a lot of this work
is going to be exhibited.
I'm having a solo show
at CCA in September.
Everyone here is invited too.
And I'm going to present this work.
So the project visualizes hip-hop
lyrics as a cultural indicator.
I mean, you can imagine overlaying
data sets, health data sets,
crime statistic data sets, education
data sets down to a county level,
and overlaying those
with this data set.
And this is data prahn [phonetic].
This is the analysis of --
the semantic analysis of Drake's
entire body of work being processed.
Cool, but data needs memory, right?
It's nice to have -- it's nice
to have pages and pages of data,
you know, whether it's machine
readable or human readable,
but in order to tell
a story with data,
you kind of need an experience
tied to it to bring it to life.
And it was this question
or these types of questions
that made me start
the Rap Research Lab.
And especially like this question:
should a culture own its own data?
Like, who is responsible
for protecting this data?
Who is responsible for telling
the stories about this data?
Who is responsible for
checking the stories told
about this cultural data?
And even when technological
development advances its workers
into exciting new spaces of
creative inquiry, the opportunity
to challenge traditional modes
of hierarchy is often missed.
And most of the time, if there's
a new space open in science,
we bring our same biases to these
open spaces; instead of trying
to do something new or
imagining something new,
we just [inaudible] our
old self to the new spaces.
So in the age of big
data, normative narratives
around hip-hop reproduce
stereotypes.
And also that -- for me that
also extends to the singularity
and artificial intelligence.
Like, you know, the singularity
in a way is a colonizing process.
It ignores what happens on
the sides and just focuses
on what works for the system.
So I founded the Rap Research Lab
to have a space and to invite people
to talk about these questions,
explore these questions
and grapple with these questions.
And the Rap Research Lab is
a creative technology studio,
and we explore rap as a cultural
indicator through educational,
editorial, and creative
interrogations.
I'm going to read a bit.
We are a team of researchers,
radical educators, technologists,
and artists who use rap
as text through which
to better understand
popular and youth culture.
We explore questions of social
justice and facilitate resilience
through community data projects.
And we design projects and ask
questions both collaboratively
and individually that
challenge notions of ownership
and agency in these spaces.
So just a few axioms,
rules off the top
that we believe at
the Rap Research Lab.
One is rap is the most influential
global and youth art form, period.
According to a Spotify analysis
of 20 billion streamed songs back
in 2015, rap is the most popular,
most listened to genre in the world.
According to a recent study,
rap is more popular than rock,
but we already knew that.
I mean, rap has more words.
Another axiom is hip-hop
isn't rap, graffiti, deejaying
and breakdancing; hip-hop
created rap, graffiti,
deejaying and breakdancing.
So in the beginning
there was a deejay.
There were no hip-hop records.
So Kool Herc playing in
1973 in the Bronx, you know,
that's cited as the
first hip-hop party.
There were no rap records.
There were no hip-hop records.
There were soul records,
there were funk records,
there were blues records,
there were rock records.
But what was hip-hop was the
way he played those records.
So hip-hop is a framework,
and the framework
in which he played those records.
And this is a quote from my
colleague David Goldberg.
This framework is helpful.
In a fragmented world, hip-hop
is an effective approach
to problem-solving, especially
when your future depends on rising
from the ruins of inherited
mistakes.
So because of this
framework, we decided to teach.
And this is a map of our
curriculum and our lesson plans.
And we start with an
introduction, you know,
the history of the technology,
the history of the culture.
And then we teach the students
how to roadmap their research.
So we teach them how
to ask questions,
how to formulate good
research questions.
And then we have a content coding
exercise where we do closed readings
of the lyrics and content code them.
This is analog.
We also have a digital version.
And then we teach the students how
to conduct a search,
how to use the tools.
And then we deal with data bias,
like their own implicit
bias and then external bias.
So how did they collect the data?
What did they leave out?
What was left out in
the initial process
of the data that they collected?
And how things fall
off along the way.
And then we have some mapping
lessons and visualization lessons.
So I'm going to read it again.
So the methodologies in this
framework, we invite participants
to engage critically with
cultural research, data collection,
data ethics, implicit bias, data
bias, and storytelling, right?
And these are the elements
that ultimately empower the critical
thinking and decision making
that leads a citizen
to become more capable
of establishing informed positions.
This outcome not only influences
behavioral change but is a precursor
to developing and deploying
a healthy democracy,
especially in this post-truth era.
So we're dealing with data
literacy, media literacy,
and actually listening to
rap and having fun doing it.
I'm making this sound so
boring, but it's really cool.
So this is -- so the next three
slides, so in terms of development
and process, we piloted a few
years ago, then we scaled up.
I invited teachers to
produce the curriculum with me
and then a third phase
was the spread.
So this is my one-room school
house in the Bronx, South Bronx.
And down on the bottom right, this
is a design sprint that we have
where we invited educators
in to test our curriculum.
And on the top right is actually the
graduation day where I invited some
of my colleagues in the art and
tech world to come and give critique
and support to the students.
Top left, that's a picture
of me waxing poetic.
And on the bottom left is one
of our content coding exercises
where we ask the students to
identify in this case five themes
that they think they'll
find in the music.
In this case, it was body
sexuality, and then achievements,
and then relationships,
love, family,
and then conflict,
and origins, politics.
And then we give them text and
then we ask them to content code.
So every time they see one of these
themes, they tag it in the text.
And that's the analog process that
helps build algorithmic thinking.
And then it's also modeled
in a digital process.
And this is the scale.
This is when we scaled up.
And these are some of the
workshops we did in collaboration
with the Parks Department,
Eye Beam and Hive,
Mozilla and Creative Capital.
And then the last phase that we just
finished last year was the spread
where we took our curriculum
and we trained New York City
Parks Department educators
to implement our curriculum in
ten locations, in five boroughs,
for nine months around
New York City.
And it was a trip.
It was a trip to see students study
me and my process on their screen.
But it was exciting to see that this
process could be spread and scaled
so I wouldn't have to
be the only one standing
in front of the classroom.
And these are some of the
-- I'm going to look at two,
show you two student projects.
So we have a student research page.
And one student, Gabriel, he
was interested in doing research
on the N word in hip-hop,
in all of hip-hop.
And he quickly realized
that that was too much data
for him to process, right?
So he was kind of bummed
out, and I was like,
"So what do you want to do?"
Then he realized in his research
that there was one artist
that had a song where he mentions
the N word like almost 200 times.
So he decides to focus on that
artist and content code all
of his songs through a lens of this
dictionary of slang that gives seven
or eight -- that gives eight
meanings of the N word.
So what you're seeing is a digital
content coding project from Gabriel.
So these are the songs on his
dropdown menu, and on the right,
these are the different
descriptions.
So a close friend, the black
experience, just a generic term,
someone's lover, someone
that's rebellious,
something that's disrespectful,
something that's negative,
and also just a filler, just to,
you know, to fill sonic space.
This is the project by Emmanuel who
was reading some of the articles
about rappers and raps that would
be used as testimony in court.
And he wanted to investigate
the differences, or whether
or not there was a difference
between crimes that were rapped
about and actually crimes
that were happening.
So this is a map that he made.
And you can see that there's -- I
mean, correlation and cause aren't,
you know, aren't tied,
but there's a difference.
So when crime is down
basically crime raps are high.
And I'm going to close with
this one quote by DJ Premier,
and he's talking about producing
Jay-Z's Reasonable Doubt album,
his first album.
And he says basically one thing he
loves about hip-hop is that you have
to understand how to listen to it.
Just because Jay-Z is speaking
in English doesn't mean you
understand what he's saying.
And that's the reason for the Rap
Research Lab, to do a deep dive into
and decoding the most
popular art form in the world.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.